hey guys what's up this is andrew for
chances.com so in this video guys i'm
here to make a big update on amc we had
a lot of things happening this week we
have a very nice bullish and girl thing
so we're gonna see what it means for the
coming week and you're gonna see that
this is good news let's get into it
[Music]
all right guys so as usual amc chart
let's start so we are in a downtrend
guys since we broke out uh from this
huge triangle okay and what we are
trying to so this triangle abcde
and this was the breakup guys okay so
since then you can watch my videos i
have always said that we are in a
process that will take time that
recovery will be long i was talking
about different levels uh 14.5 level is
a level i'm talking about four maybe two
months or something like that maybe one
month and a half maybe since we're here
and it's still holding very well so
let's see if if it's holding i mean for
the coming week and the coming month but
for now we have good signals so let me
go through the positive information we
have here so first we have this breakout
that we have analyzed already together
that is not perfect guys uh because we
missed the consolidation we didn't have
a tight bollinger bands
right here and you know it was just not
a perfect breakout so when the breakout
is not perfect and guys i'm explaining
this very well in my course that by the
way guys is released today and my
website
tradingsensors.com is finally available
as well so i'm talking about this guys
for maybe one one year one year i'm
doing videos and i'm always saying
welcome to trainingsenses.com and
finally guys you can see it so just
click on the link in description of this
video you have my website you have the
subscription link to get a 50 discount
guys that is gonna be available for one
week and on my website guys once again
it's been one year i'm building this
project one year i quit my job a little
bit less i quit my job nine months ago
and guys i'm fully dedicated to teach
you what i have learned during my career
as a professional trader in this course
guys i will show you everything that i
know and i learned even more guys by
writing this course i did everything by
myself what you're going to find in this
course 90 of it is from my experience
i'm gonna use basic concepts and i'm
gonna show you how to combine it to make
your view to take good trades with good
risk management i mean i can't explain
everything that is in there but just go
there
watch it you're gonna learn so much
you're gonna love it and if you don't
like it you are fully refunded after two
weeks on my website you will also find
my first article guys i hope you're
gonna like it i wrote it myself so sorry
for the mistakes if there are some you
know i like to work by myself i will of
course build a team grow but for now
it's only me guys me and gabrielle who
is helping me who's a trader helping me
they're the two of us guys we're going
to make something amazing so just join
and you're going to love it so let's go
back to amc guys amc i was saying we
have this breakout so once again that is
not good quality so this is the reason
why it got not even re-tested you know
we went even lower than that okay so
this is hap this is happening when the
breakout is not good quality i'm gonna
explain in my course what you should do
in this situation but here maybe buy
around the 61.8 to 20-day moving average
would be great around 16-17 it's risky
because you know the stop-loss would
have been put maybe around you know 14.
so it would have worked but maybe it i'm
not sure how i would have set up a trade
on this setup particularly using my
course but
the thing is that this is amc guys so
technical analysis is very helpful but
you guys know that we have a lot of
manipulation the stock is very tough to
uh trade and you know you just need to
adapt a little bit the usual techniques
so in this situation we are bullish and
what i wanted to show you guys is this
bullish engulfing all right so this is
very interesting so stay with me guys
i'm going to show you something cool
what is a bullish angle thing is when
one candle fully engulfs so here this
green candle guys as you can see this
huge green candle is angle thing totally
this one all right so this one green
candle is angle thing the small red
candle before this is the reason why
it's called a bullish engulfing it's a
reversal pattern that is giving good
results when found at the end of a
downtrend so what is a downtrend right
so it's you should have three or four
red candles how many do we have one two
three four
it's working so in this situation we
should have a move up and if you want to
check guys this is very cool look at
what i'm going to show you and in my
course guys i'm going to show you many
things like this you just click here
guys you type engulfing okay so i'm on
training view i click on indicators i
type engulfing i select the bullish
angle thing here bam and all the bullish
anger things appear alright so you can
check how they worked in the past and we
can quickly analyze guys we had one here
so this one was not very good guys this
was the b wave bull trap all right
because we had an thing we had we moved
a little bit higher and then we got
hammered so this one was a fail okay
then this one
same thing we we had a positive reaction
you know
15 percent it's not nothing but frame c
it's not that big guys but we moved up
50 and then we moved lower but we still
had a positive reaction what we can see
is that here we had two green days then
uh we got lower we went lower here we
have
one two three three green days but
strong then we moved very strongly lower
here we have one as well guys but this
one is not very beautiful because it's
not at the end of a downtrend as you can
see we have one green one red candle so
this one is not really working it still
gave us a positive reaction and we had
one beautiful here that god gave us this
uh beautiful move up of 60
okay so what i can see is that all of
them gave me 15
60
16
and even this one three percent okay so
between three and 16 up in the past few
months uh looking at the past four
bullish and girl things that we had so
what can i say guys i mean you know this
is training it's about probabilities so
i would say that it's more likely we're
more likely to see amc going higher than
lower because we have the breakout
bullish momentum that is still here guys
this breakout is a medium term breakout
it's still going to attract some bulls
you know that going to buy the deep
after this kind of event all right even
if it's not a perfect breakout once
again i'm gonna explain exactly why it's
not perfect but already gave you a lot
of information the consolidation was not
perfect the volume increases here but
not amazing
so even after this non-perfect event
you're still going to have a lot of
buyers that are going to buy the dip all
right and at 14.5 there were buyers so
we have those buyers and we have the
bullish engulfing traders that are gonna
you know probably enter here so i'm
gonna make a video about snp and triple
q spy triple q because it's about you
know the global market as well if the
global market really tanks uh maybe
we're gonna see some negative beta again
we saw guys during the day they were so
thursday and friday thursday s p was uh
dropping heavily amc was up guys all
right
amc started down but it was up
quicker than the s p 500 so at the end
of the day we don't have a negative beta
but during the day it was a negative
better day yesterday friday was also a
negative better day the s p 500 was up
two percent or one percent at the
beginning of the day and amc was
dropping three four five percent and at
the end of the day mc was all right flat
so at the end of the day we don't have a
negative beta day but during the day it
was so maybe guys there's something
happening here what i mean is that uh
the global market
trend is gonna sentiment is gonna affect
of course amc as well and even if we
drop on the global market we still can
go higher on amc so everything can
happen but we have some good news to me
from the breakout from the bullish
engulfing the global market is strong
guys once again i'm gonna make a food
analysis on that but it looks
i'm not sure it looks a bit like a dead
cat bounce to be honest but i need to
analyze deeply and i will share my
analysis in uh two days guys i'm gonna
make it today but post it on monday
morning so you're gonna have it before
market open on monday uh so here to
conclude and we have earnings coming
here so guys i don't know i want to
believe in a scenario where we just go
you know we just go higher we've seen
last week that usually before earnings
we have on the day of the earnings the
market likes to shift we've seen that
last week you can check my video i was
saying that either we go to 14.5 then
rebound or go to i was saying here so i
don't think we can reach that level
right now i didn't know the russia
ukraine war would be that bad so right
now i would like to see a rally but
i think we might go to this level and
then maybe correct and go higher you
know this is the most likely scenario
from now something like that
okay
so let's see guys i hope this scenario
would happen the alternative scenario is
that once again we go come back here and
then go strongly higher but we have the
bullish engulfing so it doesn't look
like this would happen so i think a
bullish week is ahead of us uh let's see
how the market reacts to earnings once
again the major resistance level guys is
here so the first time we're gonna get
here it will probably be rejected so
rejected then coming back consolidate
and then break out yes so once again i
think we're gonna have some nice moves
happening around april may so let's find
out let's see what's gonna happen i hope
you guys enjoyed this video and don't
forget guys to check my website and to
subscribe to get a 50 discount for one
week only all right guys thank you very
much for watching this video and click
on the sub like and bell button if you
want to see more and stay close to shore